Before we get started, we wanna remind you
that this is the last episode
before we take three weeks off
so three week break,
opportunity for you to listen
to some older Ear Biscuits,
maybe one you missed
or your favorite one.
And we'll be back on August 19th,
right after we get back
from our big vacations
that we will fill you in all about.
Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we ask the question are we too nice?
Hmm.
Are we too nice?
You mean like Too Nice,
like the old, wasn't there
a musician named Too Nice?
There was a rapper named D-Nice.
Ah, there wasn't a Too Nice
with like a Too and then a Nice?
My name is D-Nice.
I remember your brother owned that CD.
I thought that was Denice.
And it wasn't that memorable.
See, Jacob said there was a Too Nice.
There's also a Too Nice?
Well look up D-Nice because the letter D,
the space which is a space
and then the word Nice.
'Cause Too Nice doesn't
sound like a cool name
for a musician.
You don't wanna be too nice--
D dash Nice.
Oh I know, Cole had that
CD and I'd go into his room
when I was going over to your house.
He had it all.
Hanging out with you.
You didn't even have a CD player.
He had a CD player,
man, and he had rap CDs
and I'd go in there and I'd listen to him.
I'd listen to them.
Listen to him.
Well I'd listen to him talk about his CDs
and occasionally he'd play them.
He had much better music
taste than you did.
Well he was, I think he also was--
It's the older brother syndrome.
Older brother, yeah, it's
like I technically had access
to his library.
I knew it was all being handed
down to me at some point.
Yeah but you couldn't play it though
because you didn't have a CD player.
I eventually had a CD player.
Of course eventually you did.
But I had a tape player for a long time.
There was a weird moment
when he transitioned
to CDs where I was a little
bit left in the dark.
But also we had thin walls in the house
and we shared a wall so I kind of listened
to muffled D-Nice.
Did you ever talk to him through the wall?
I mean I never, I know this is
not what we're talking about
but we're talking about it.
This relates to my dream .
It's kinda funny.
Your dream?
I have to tell you the dream
I had that you were in.
All right so we're gonna
talk about are we too nice.
It is a question that
we've asked ourselves--
I did talk to him.
And each other many times--
Through the wall.
But first your dream.
I yelled at him through
the wall and vice versa.
Shut up!
That kinda thing, you know.
That's ironic.
But there was no prison
sort of communication
between the two walls.
And the reason I say prison is
because that's what my dream was about
and I believe and my wife pointed this out
when I told her about this dream.
She said the reason you
dreamed this is because
of that question that we got
in the live LTAT at VidCon
where the question was who
would survive better in prison?
And your answer was not me.
I just said I don't think
Linky Poo would do too well.
In prison.
I didn't know what you meant by that.
I think most people do.
That wasn't very nice.
Yeah I'm not Too Nice, man.
I'm D-Nice.
Okay so I had a dream
that you were in prison
and you were in prison--
For murder.
Oh crap.
I knew no details.
All I knew is that you
had been falsely accused.
Oh good.
And I don't know if it
was because I just knew
in your character so well
that you're not capable
of murder but I just
think that the pretense--
Don't think Linky Poo's capable of murder.
The pretense in the dream
was that I was going
to talk to you about how we were going
to get you out legally, not
break you out but I was like,
this is a false accusation so
for some reason the
prison was in Keith Hills.
So the golf course,
the gated neighborhood,
slash golf course that was
next to where we both grew up
in Buies Creek.
That we're going to next week.
We're going to visit and--
So all this is on your mind.
Yes.
Maybe there is a, I know they
expanded the golf course.
I have not heard that they added a prison.
Well golfers can be very,
very disorderly sometimes.
They break clubs and
stuff, it would be nice
to have a detention center for them.
So you were on your way to the prison
which was in the golf course.
I got, no, I was at the prison.
And the prison was near the river.
The prison was basically where
we're going to be next week,
in that area where Cinder
Morgan's old house was.
Okay.
And so I go
and my mission is to
talk to you about like,
dude we've gotta get a lawyer.
We need to engage, we
have to try to fight this,
and you were completely disengaged.
It was like--
I'd settled in.
You had completely
settled in, you were like--
See, I'd do well in prison.
Well you do well--
I make myself right at home.
You do well in golf prison.
You do well in golf prison, but--
Did it have golf course accoutrements?
No it was--
Or was there like--
It was like, well, I'll explain it.
It was almost like it was just a building.
Maybe with a gate.
Low security.
Like a medium to low
security prison for murder.
And--
Who did I kill supposedly?
I don't have the details of the murder.
It didn't register with me,
I just knew that you were innocent
and I was like I gotta
talk to Link about this
but when I began talking to you about it,
again, you were not responsive to the idea
of challenging this.
Was I dejected
or was I happy?
What was my state?
You were indifferent, you were disengaged
and I was very mad.
I was very upset with you.
Yeah 'cause I did wanna get
into also your emotional state
'cause I think this could be revealing.
So before I made you angry,
what was your emotional state?
Were you crying or were you--
The beginning of the dream at least as far
as I remember was I am at golf prison
and I've gotta figure this out,
I gotta get Link out of here.
It was just very much just that was it
and then I go in there
and start talking to you
in the area where you
can talk to prisoners.
You have on an orange shirt,
orange jumpsuit.
Was there--
No I'm saying--
Was there glass?
I'm sitting at a table with you.
Okay.
And--
But no touching.
And I was like hey man,
you didn't do this.
We gotta get your story out there
and you just weren't saying anything.
You were kinda just looking at me like
why are you so upset about this?
So then, the door opens.
Oh.
And I'm like this isn't just the door
to the room opens and there's a hall,
no the door opens and there's just woods.
It's like--
Oh yeah.
Not a well designed prison.
The door opens and we can totally get out.
Was there music and a special light like
♪ Ah ♪
That doesn't happen in my dreams.
So I looked at you and
I was like let's go.
Because what was happening in my brain was
we gotta go through this
long legal procedure
to get him out.
He's not even on board.
Were you thinking about content?
Were you thinking about our careers
or were you just thinking
about our friendship?
I really need to know, Rhett.
I can make up an answer.
Be honest.
That would make you feel
a certain way.
No.
No no I'm saying I don't know.
Oh, oh.
It's a dream.
It's a fragmented reality,
you know what I'm saying.
It was probably all wrapped up together.
So--
I was probably thinking
like prison content.
The funny thing is is as you...
It took you a second to
be like okay I'm gonna go
but you ran out after me.
And my old Dodge Intrepid that I drove
at the end of high
school and the beginning
of college was the car that I was driving
because that's how these
things happen in dreams.
And I just get into the
Intrepid and start driving
and you are running after the Intrepid.
Like catching a train?
So in other words, I'm
running away without the guy
that I'm trying to get out of prison.
It's like where am I going?
I just visited prison, I don't
have to leave in a hurry.
It seemed that I had a motivation issue
so you really needed to,
needed to get me off the dime.
Then you're running next to the car
and then I'm like get into the car.
And you're like but my shirt is messed up.
What?
And I look and the sleeves
of your orange jumpsuit
are detached and you've taped them on
and you're trying to get the tape right.
That's important.
Can't get into a getaway vehicle--
And I'm like--
If your sleeves
are not perfect.
I'm like don't worry about the jumpsuit!
Get in the Intrepid!
Ironically it would have been
better to shed the jumpsuit.
You don't wanna be driving around town
in an Intrepid with a prison uniform on.
Did it have golf insignias
or anything on it?
No golf relation.
There was nothing related to golf.
Did I get in?
You got in.
We start driving down
that part of the circle
in Keith Hills and we're driving
towards Wiggin's old house,
coming around that way.
The big house.
Well I guess prison's a big house
but he had a large house.
And apparently the security
response is incredibly quick
'cause literally we've been out of prison
for 17 seconds and there's already cops
with teams of dogs--
Wow.
Cops with teams of dogs
coming through the yards
along all the houses
right there on the river.
Just coming out of the woodwork.
And we just drive by them.
Slow?
Yeah, we didn't wanna draw any attention.
Just keep it cool.
I wanted to make sure
they saw your orange sleeves.
That guy's sleeves are in tact.
Well they're taped a little bit, nah,
doesn't seem suspicious.
Now and as is the case
with a lot of dreams
that reach a real point
of excitement like that,
I woke up at that moment.
You woke up.
Then the weirdest thing happened.
Now this was Saturday night.
I ended up staying Saturday night
because Locke ended up
having some games in Anaheim,
basketball games so I was like oh,
I've already got the hotel room,
I'll just say at VidCon for another day.
So this dream woke me up at
about five o'clock in the morning.
Mm-hmm.
Now I had every reason and
intention to go back to sleep
but the thing that I could
not stop thinking about
is how to get away from the cops.
While you were awake?
I was awake.
And I was literally, I was
trying to go back to sleep
and as I would go back to sleep,
the thing that I would
almost begin dreaming about
was picking up the chase where it left off
and what I was gonna do, like
a choose your own adventure.
And I went through all
these things, I was like,
well they're definitely
trying to drive out.
There's only one way out of the gate.
They're gonna have the gate
barricaded, we can't get out
so what we should have done
is we should have gone down
to the river and I was like
should we have crossed the river?
No 'cause they would find us,
they've got helicopters and
stuff and I was like no,
what we should have done,
'cause we should have waited
until it was night and
then we should have gotten
into a canoe and gone way down the river
and then we should have
gotten out of the river
at one of those places
where there was a little hut
for fishing and hunting
that sometimes people build
on the river.
Yeah.
And then let the boat
continue to go down the river
so they'll find the boat
miles down the river
and so they won't be
able, I thought about this
for 45 minutes.
Might have thought we,
that we did, you find
the canoe, it's broken up
on some rapids.
Oh they drowned, yeah.
But really we're just livin' large
in some little catfish hut.
Could have taken off the
jumpsuit or at least the sleeves,
put 'em in the river, like oh.
He either lost his arms,
his sleeves or he dissolved.
Yeah you gotta throw some
articles of clothing--
So you were thinking all of this.
Trying to go back to sleep,
not wanting to think it
but I was like if I don't
figure out the best way
to get away from the
cops at the golf prison,
I'm not gonna be able to get good sleep
and when I figured out I
think it's canoeing at night,
then I was like okay and
I went back to sleep.
Haven't thought about it since.
I don't think we ever
actually canoed at night.
Did we?
Of all the canoeing that we
did on the Cape Fear River--
No, I did a lot of--
I don't recall any night canoeing.
A lot of night fishing, night fishing,
and we did a lot of night river crossing.
Yeah.
'Cause sometimes we would get down there
too late or whatever.
It's dangerous to be, I mean you need
to have a spotlight I would think in order
to navigate any rapids or whatever.
I also wonder is there,
I bet you there is a golf
prison somewhere in the world
and it's probably Sweden.
Isn't that where the
really posh prisons are?
Is that one of the Scandinavian--
Scandinavian prisons in general are nice.
Norwegian prisons are nice.
Are golf courses nice in Scandinavia?
Why am I asking you?
I would think so, why would they be bad?
'Cause it's cold.
It's icy, it gets snowy up there.
But it's not always snowy.
Under the snow there's a nice golf prison.
It only opens in the summer
and then in the winter,
we send the prisoners to
the ski resort prison.
That's what they do.
I don't know how it works.
But if I am ever gonna kill somebody,
it will be in Scandinavia.
I do think if I went to prison,
our working relation, this
is how it would play out.
You would have to do all the thinking.
I mean, I'm not gonna sit
in there like the Hurricane and try
to figure out my own defense
and start writing letters to--
I see that.
To advocates
who can come in and get me out of prison.
You'll just be like well--
Well.
This is just how it is man.
Don't worry so much about it.
I've already started etching
how many days I'm here
on my cell and I've started
way up here in the corner.
So I don't wanna run out of space.
I'd be thinking things like that.
Right.
You gotta think strategic.
You don't wanna start
etching the days on your cell
right in the middle and
then what are you gonna do,
a spiral pattern?
No you gotta start in an
upper right-hand corner.
I don't think they let you do that anymore
and I also don't think it's necessary
'cause I think you just ask
the guard what's the date
and he just tells you.
Or you ask your caddy at the golf prison.
It's like how many yards to my release?
Do I need a three iron to get out of here?
Is that a thing, a three iron?
No three iron is a thing, yeah.
It's nine irons.
I wonder how it would impact the prison.
Is that true, are there nine irons?
Well it just depends on
what bag you're in but yeah.
Nine iron is the highest numbered iron.
Okay, see, I know stuff.
There are as many as three or four irons
of increasing waft above that
that are called pitching wedge
and sand wedge and lock
wedge and gap wedge
and things like that.
And then some people like
my father and me by the way,
we don't play with a three iron,
we play with a three hybrid.
It's for people who need
a little bit more help
because it's hard to hit those long irons.
These are the kinda
conversations I'm having
in prison by the way.
Well I'm gonna teach--
I'm a gang leader, I'm a golf gang leader.
I'm gonna teach golf in golf prison.
Oh that's your in.
That's how I get into the prison.
Then you're sneaking over there
and digging a hole for me.
With a three iron 'cause I don't use it,
I might use it to hit a golf ball with.
Christy and I--
The shovel.
Christy and I got in a
little kerfuffle about
in the wake of the earthquakes
and we were talking
about the dynamic of
why she's gathering all
this earthquake stuff and
ordering it and I was like,
she's baffled by my...
Just like I was acting in golf prison,
just kinda, okay, it'll be fine.
If I ignore the fact I'm in golf prison
I think it'll be okay.
And I'm like--
Where's that come from?
I don't know, I think it's--
It's your coping mechanism.
I don't know what the word
is, if it's codependency
or if it's just laziness
but when you were ordering
all that apocalypse
stuff and I was like hey,
can you just double your order?
You graciously did and
I felt good about that.
It feels good knowing that
someone else is worrying
about it and I said,
"Christy it's not that
"I don't think it's valid,
it's that I think that,
"I trust you, I know
that you're very attuned
"to the dangers associated
with it and being prepared
"as much as possible."
So I know I don't have
to worry about that.
I have this, to a fault, I
have this heightened sense
of brain power allocation.
And if I start allocating
brain power to earthquake
or apocalypse preparedness,
that's less I've got
to allocate towards something else like
perfectly optimizing our vacation plans.
So that was my response
to Christy, I was like,
you got this, girl.
And I got this, girl.
So let's not, there's no
implied judgment here,
but it does make me look a
little stupid where it's like--
You looked pretty stupid
in the dream, yeah.
Well I think it was the sleeves.
It was the sleeves.
They didn't help.
I mean they were taped.
You shouldn't have taped 'em.
You should have just gone
sleeveless because that's a look
that I think would work in golf prison.
Right, you really assert yourself.
Has there ever been a
golfer and I'm not talking
about in prison--
I think it's--
Sleeveless?
I think it's against the dress code.
They got a dress code?
Yeah I think--
Golf and tennis,
they need to loosen up.
You have to have your shirt tucked in.
I don't know.
Basketball players have
to tuck their shirt in but I think
that there's something to do with safety.
I think it's just respecting the game.
And defense.
It's really just respect.
You don't have to wear--
It's control.
Well you don't, and I think Tiger was--
It's old farts trying to seem like they--
Well no, I don't necessarily think so.
I think it's just, it's a tradition
but I think Tiger wears
that mock turtleneck
a lot of times, he wears red on Sunday.
And that's pushing the limits?
I don't recall specifically
but my guess is
is that it must have been controversial
when he decided to wear
that the first time.
It's like oh he doesn't have a collar.
Maybe there was a
discussion about the rules
at that point, I don't
know, somebody look that up.
His shirt doesn't button and it creeps up
to the bottom of his Adam's apple.
It's almost a turtleneck
but it kinda feels like
it's just pretending to be a turtleneck.
Let's call it a mock turtleneck.
Okay well that's not what
we're gonna talk about.
We're not gonna talk anymore
about golf and turtlenecks
and prison or golf
prison, we're gonna talk
about whether or not we're too nice
and how that relates
to some personal things
and also some professional things.
But first we wanna let you know,
you think you can grab that pin?
You think you can reach
all the way and grab that?
Yeah.
You ready?
Look at that.
This is the Mythical Society
pin, Semper Curiosus.
Which second and third tier members
of the Mythical Society
got when they signed up.
We're making it available
to everyone in the Mythical Society.
I didn't say, you thought
I was gonna say everyone.
Everyone in the Mythical Society
at Mythical.store but you're gonna be,
at the Mythical Store,
there's going to be--
For purchase.
A code that you can,
I don't exactly know how it is
but if you're on the Society,
you will know how to get to
the listing at Mythical.store
and then how to buy it.
Cool little pin.
Check out the Mythical Society.
Sign up.
I guarantee you'll love it.
Wow that's quite a guarantee.
If you don't you can always quit it but
I betcha that won't happen.
That's your right though.
This pin is really cool
and we got other cool pins
on the Mythical Store.
That Cotton Candy Randy pin, man.
I've seen some pictures of that thing
and his legs are gonna jump
out and whisper in your ear.
It's a great design.
Yeah.
Mythical.store.
Are we too nice?
I really don't know where
this conversation's gonna go.
Maybe we can tee it up with...
It is true that we do
find ourselves asking
that question at times.
There's different ways to look at this.
I'm gonna let you start in where you want.
I'm just kinda setting the table.
'Cause I think that
there's our public persona,
like part of our brain
is that we're nice guys.
But I'd like to, so we can explore that.
And it's not just public, it's,
I do like to believe that it's private.
And then obviously we can
explore the personal nature
of yeah, I think we're nice guys.
Well my most--
Not 'cause we're southern.
Is that just--
I think it's part of it.
What are the reasons?
We talked at some point
about our conflict avoidance
and how that was sort of
a deeply southern thing.
I think some of it is related to that
and for me the most interesting aspect
of this conversation is professionally
and how it relates to
our content but I do,
because it's so fresh, I
do and it's very relevant,
I wanna tell the story that
happened before my dream
and was probably the
meal that I was digesting
when I had my dream.
Okay.
Which is a Saturday night
dinner with my family.
Now I've never taken my
entire family to VidCon.
And this was the first time
that that had happened.
They came in a little bit late
and it turns out Locke had
a couple of basketball games
in Anaheim that we had
to stick around for,
I think I already said this.
Just told os many people
now, I'm repeating things.
But so we spent the
night on Saturday night
and we were gonna go grab some dinner
and I was like, we should do something
that's not super close to
VidCon because there'll be
a bunch of people from VidCon
and technically you're not
even really supposed to,
we're not supposed to be out
and about anywhere near VidCon,
it's a security concern, right,
so they don't even let us do it.
And if you do, that's another night
where you have to be nice.
You have to manufacture niceness for fans.
Right.
Because you're so mean in real life
which we'll get to later.
And so you know that restaurant Roy's?
There's one in Pasadena.
It's a Hawaiian place.
Never heard of it.
I've seen it around, it's a
chain that I think is not,
it doesn't' go outside of California.
Maybe it does, I don't know.
But we wanted to go there.
A Hawaiian restaurant?
It's a Hawaiian steakhouse,
like a upscale Hawaiian restaurant.
Okay.
So not like a Hawaiian
barbecue strip mall situation.
And I was like okay let's go there
and didn't realize that
it was actually very close
to the convention center, it
was far away from the hotel
but it was close to the convention center
and so I got a little bit
nervous as we're pulling up.
It was kinda late, I
was like there might be,
so then as we're driving, it's
sort of like an outdoor mall
kind of area, I do see a lot
of lanyards and I'm like,
ah this is kind of a VidCon crowd
and we had just done our meet and greet,
and not that I don't have a,
I was actually just worried
about kinda violating the rules honestly.
But I was also like
the kids had been here,
I haven't spent a lot of time with them
and I kinda wanna just go
have a nice dinner with them.
So I told Jessie as we were
pulling into the parking garage,
I was like I'm gonna do the
thing that we talked about
on a previous--
The Sterling K Brown.
Sterling K Brown, we just
call it the Sterling K Brown.
That is what it is.
And that is when if approached,
you say I'm with my family,
I'm sorry, if somebody wants a picture
or somebody wants an
autograph or whatever,
you just say I'm sorry,
I'm with my family.
And that's a very difficult thing,
I don't know if you've instituted that,
how many times you've instituted that,
it's a very difficult thing for me to do
because I am a nice guy, right?
And also for all the
reasons that we talked about
in the past, I feel a
sense of obligation to fans
to be nice and give them a moment.
Now, so I go in but I'm like
I'm gonna hold to this, guys.
I was like I'm gonna do
the Sterling K Brown.
We get out of the, and
everybody's on board,
family's on board seemingly at the time.
We get out of the car,
we go to the elevator
that is gonna--
Roy got a elevator?
No no it was like there was a parking deck
and then it was an outdoor
mall so you gotta go
from the parking deck up to the--
Like dang.
Roy doesn't have an
elevator that I know of.
And we're getting ready
to get on the elevator.
My dad has an elevator in his beach house.
That's cool.
Just bragging a little.
And a woman--
His house is on stilts.
A mom and a little girl,
probably 12.
Immediate test.
Come up, now, I recognize at least the mom
but I think both of them
from the meet and greet.
They had just been in the meet and greet.
I have thoughts but go ahead.
But I kinda didn't remember that
until after they went away
to be honest with you.
I was like oh crap, they
were at the meet and greet.
250 people, you can't remember everybody.
I bet they remembered it.
So I said, she comes up and she's like,
I saw them looking at me
and I was like here we go.
Little girl comes up, she's
got a bag and she's like,
"Would you please sign this?"
And when you say here we
go, you're like here we go,
this is a test in front of my family
if I'm gonna Sterling K Brown this moment.
Yeah.
Okay, she had the bag.
She says, "Will you please sign this?"
And what's the family
configuration at this point
because I think that's important.
It's four people in my family.
I know who's in your,
I mean physically where are they standing?
We're all standing outside of an elevator
waiting for it to open.
Okay.
And I will say that no
one else was around, okay?
No one else was around but I
had literally in the car not--
Just said--
30 seconds ago said,
"I'm Sterling K Browning this situation."
And I'm not going off of that.
Little girl says, "Will
you please sign this?"
And I was like, "I'm
sorry, I'm with my family."
Oh, dude.
Okay okay okay.
She looks a little
upset, a little shocked,
including the mom.
But they were nice enough,
when you say family
they're like okay and then
they kinda just went away.
We get on the elevator, Shepherd says,
"Dad, that was a little girl."
I'm like...
And then Locke's like, "Yeah
and nobody was around."
I'm like I'm doing this for y'all!
Why you gotta criticize me?
Dang.
Because if you would have
done it, you would have got
on the elevator and you
imagined it playing out as
you would have turned and said
hey, it was a little girl.
And there was no one else around.
Right, and I got so close
to doing it but I was like
this is the first test.
And you know what, and what else,
and then what did they say?
Well it continued of course
throughout the night.
I just mean the assessment of that,
was that the end of that or did
they say but you know what--
No no no, I said you know what--
We're glad you did it.
I feel bad.
I probably should have called
an audible in that situation.
No.
I gotta read the environment better.
No!
But that requires too much thinking.
No no no no no, listen--
You think I was still right?
Your boys--
I'm a nice guy.
Too nice.
I think they didn't
articulate what they felt
which was prioritize, man.
That's the point.
And you know what, you
did the right thing.
You did the nice thing,
you were nice to those
that you love the most for once.
Yeah yeah that's right.
When we were walking the floor at VidCon,
you asked if I've done the
Sterling K Brown thing.
Oh yeah yeah yeah.
And then I'll let you
continue with your story.
I'm talking with Lily because it was,
the Sterling K Brown thing
happened to Lily and Christy.
It was like me going up to him saying,
"My girls are big fans."
And then he Sterling K Browned me
and I gained so much
more respect for the guy
who I already had so much for.
Right.
So Lily experienced being
on the non-receiving end
of a Sterling K Brown personally and then,
and we had had this discussion
about this can become
a part of what I do.
Yeah.
So we're walking around
the convention floor when
it's just for creators
and their families but
with a lot of creators
and their families want to come up to us--
Yeah.
And get pictures taken
even in that environment.
I actually checked in with
you as we were going out
into the--
And Lily did first
and she, as we're walking in she was like,
Dad, are you gonna tell 'em,
you gonna Sterling K Brown these people?
We should call it SKB.
SKB 'em?
Yeah.
And I was like,
I've already been
thinking about that, yes.
Because they want to go to things,
they're moving and then they turn around
and I'm back taking a
picture with somebody
and it is very frustrating.
It's like a perfect place to SKB.
And she asked me about
it and I was like, yeah,
I'm gonna do that and then
it immediately happened.
And I was like I'm here with
my family and I gestured
and they were walking ahead
so it was actually perfect.
You see how you're
holding me up right now?
I'm trying to be with them.
I can't even physically be with them.
It's not like they're
standing there in an elevator
thinking that I'm the
one making the mistake.
Right.
And it felt good.
And I also did it there.
I saw Lily turn around
and she heard me say it and
then I caught up with them
and there was just a
little twinkle in the eye
and no word needed to be
said and it was like okay,
you know what--
Well my kids did not
appreciate me in the same way.
I think in their heart they might.
Oh I mean, there's a little girl.
All right just go back on it then.
No I'm not going back on it.
And I will say that--
You kept doing it?
Okay in the restaurant,
in the restaurant, well, on
the way to the restaurant,
somebody asked and I SKBed them
and then in the restaurant,
there was a family
that was sitting there and you could see
the discussion begin to happen that's like
when are we gonna go over there?
They waited until our
desserts had come or whatever.
We got through our meal.
Okay.
And I guess I just lost
heart by that point
and they asked for a
picture and I was like okay,
we can get a quick one.
I probably said it in a
very unenthusiastic way
which made them feel horrible.
That sounded pretty unenthusiastic.
Okay, we can get a quick one.
At the end of VidCon,
I'm drained unlike any--
I literally had just done
all of Saturday and we did
the meet and greet--
Oh gosh.
And then--
Yeah that's tough.
You know, it does take,
'cause we do try to be there
for people and be present
and some people have a story
to tell that maybe we don't want people
to not tell us something
if they've got something
to say but unless you're a robot
it's an emotionally draining experience
and you're kinda just ready
to pull back from all that.
Well if I may, I suggest that we skip
from fan interactions to
other types of niceties
because I thought, when you
were talking about Roy's,
I thought you were
actually gonna talk about
the most quintessential nicety
which is how was your meal?
Oh yeah.
And I think that's another--
We did a whole podcast on that.
We did a whole podcast on that one
so I don't wanna camp
out there but I think,
I still cannot say, tow
the party line of niceness
and say, 'cause here's the deal.
The opposite of nice is not mean
in this conversation.
The opposite of nice is not being a jerk
or being cold-hearted, the
opposite of nice is what?
Well sometimes honesty.
Honesty.
And it's so hard to do
it because you just,
and I think if I'm totally
honest with myself now
about being honest with
the waiter, it's like well,
the meal wasn't that great.
I was disappointed in the so and so.
It automatically, the reason
why I don't like doing it
is because it just makes you
seem like an entitled jerk.
Kinda like talking about how you got fans
and you don't wanna be nice to 'em.
Well and--
That's the risk right?
And I do think--
That's why we don't like
talking about it.
And sometimes,
and I'm sure we talked about
this when we talked about it
but and sometimes it's just not worth it
but I had this happen to me
when I was in North Carolina.
We're at a restaurant, just Jessie and I,
and it was one of those situations,
it was a waterfront restaurant,
we're sitting there,
and then about 10 minutes into,
all we had was drinks at the time,
the waiter comes up and he's like,
"Would you guys like to
move closer to the water?"
And again, it's very
difficult to not take that
as like, is this because
they knew who I am
or are they just being nice to me?
And that's a problem.
It turns out it was because
the manager was a fan.
That's how we got the table upgrade.
What's your point, you refused it?
No no no, I took it but then,
the waitress asked me what...
What do you want to drink?
As a second drink or
whatever and I was like,
the bar's got mezcal right?
I was like, I asked for a
mezcal sour which thanks
to our good friend
Jayden, he introduced me
to that drink and I really like it.
Mezcal's one of my favorite liquors.
Smoky.
And you could see on her
face that immediately
she didn't really know exactly
what I was talking about,
maybe hadn't heard that before.
Uh-oh.
But she was like I think
the bartender will be able
to figure something out
to bring me a drink,
long story short, I drank it,
the drink was really not good
at all and when she came back
and asked, "How's that drink?"
I was like, "You know--"
Oh you did it?
"It's not great."
You did it!
Yeah.
Man.
Just listen to the personal
growth on this podcast.
But here's the thing, I felt like a.
Your face really scrunched
up even when you retold it.
Because I had gotten a table upgrade.
Yeah.
Just take what you can
get at this point, man.
But the thing is is
that I kinda wanted her
to know that if somebody orders this drink
and you give them this,
they ain't gonna be happy.
That ain't it.
What did she say?
And she was like, "Oh, okay."
Oh.
And but here's where the nice guy came,
I was like, "I'll probably drink it."
And I did.
I'll probably drink it?
I kept drinking it.
That's odd.
I know, man.
Too nice.
Well okay, this morning.
Too Nice.
My name is D-Nice.
That's kinda the rhythm of the song
if I remember it correctly.
Yeah I'm doing the Too Nice stuff,
you can do the D-Nice stuff.
I had to Uber in this morning.
I was texting you, I was
like, "Can I get a ride?"
I was working out, man.
Like nothing.
And my Apple Watch battery dies.
I'm looking at the phone--
I can't get any texts--
It's like nothing.
When I'm working out.
You were texting Stevie.
I was on a three-way with you and Stevie
and you were texting her and
then I'm on this other thread
like right below it and I'm
like, "Can I get a ride?"
Nothing, and I'm like, what's going on?
And then I'm like question mark, send.
I did see that.
And then you're like
still talking to Stevie,
you're talking about being
at the gym, you were
ghosting my ride text.
I did not see--
And then you were like,
"I actually Ubered."
I didn't see any of your texts.
Why are you ghosting me?
What I was doing is I would check in
in between like--
If I were in golf prison.
I was working out and then I had
to take a shower.
I gotta have faith.
And then--
You're gonna come through
for me, man.
I never saw it
until the very end, 'til I
got through with my shower.
You had to Uber in too.
Yeah 'cause our cars were here.
Man.
I hate riding in cars where
other people are driving.
Because I'm so much better
at it than everybody.
I just don't know why...
I'm sure I'll get into it
later, like teaching Lily
to drive so I'll leave that out of this.
That's a whole other podcast.
But I just prime myself
on being a smooth driver.
People don't know how to
stop and go, they don't.
They really don't, they don't think,
you need to drive that you've got an egg.
If you--
Balancing on the dashboard.
Yes.
Okay?
That's how you make an enjoyable ride.
The DMV should sell those.
Yeah, you break the egg,
you lose your license.
Well you know what, I'm
gonna carry one around
and whenever I'm in a car
that's being chauffeured--
You break this egg, I give you two stars.
Like an Uber.
The Uber egg.
Yes.
Yeah.
Uber should sell it.
Or Lyft.
The Lyft egg,
that just sounds like you're
stealing an egg though.
Okay.
Could be called the ride share egg.
We were riding in an Uber to the airport
and I'm like if you're
a professional driver,
you should be able to
drive professionally.
I mean you should be good at it.
But nobody gets into the details--
I get car sick, man.
Of that stopping and going.
I get car sick.
They don't ever--
In the backseat.
No one teaches that and
no one is honest about it.
And I also am a control freak, yes.
It's like hey, bro.
Could you learn to slow down more smoothly
and speed up and don't keep tapping
your break every five seconds.
The guy, did you notice
it was me, you and Stevie
and we were going to the--
Horrible.
I remember.
Going to the airport
and we never talked
about it but I don't know
if you noticed at one point in the middle
of our conversation, he was
herky jerkying us around
and I start violently
gesturing with my hands
behind him in the seat
just like, I was so angry.
Yeah.
Because I was getting sick.
Right.
I was driving.
I don't get car sick,
I just don't enjoy it.
And I was so close to saying something.
He was so friendly when we got in the car
and he introduced himself,
I was like you know what,
if I would have remembered his name--
Mm, mm.
Then I might say something
now, like Raphael,
would you mind, we're not
in that big of a hurry
so would you mind, I couldn't
formulate what I would say
but because I didn't
know his name I gave up,
but let's say I did know his name.
I still don't know what I would have said
that was nice but still
got my point across
which is hey man, Raphael,
we're, how do you do this?
I don't know, Raphael,
we're not in a hurry and
I'm prone to car sickness.
Can you just, make it more
about me and my shortcomings?
I think that would be helpful, yeah.
I'm prone to car sickness.
And the real--
I'm not in hurry.
The herky jerky stopping
and going is very troublesome.
Can you just stay
in one lane and smooth it out?
I mean change lanes if we need to get,
go on a different road but otherwise,
all this aggressive stuff is
not making me like you more.
But you know it'd be a lot
easier if you'd be like,
hey Raphael, here's an egg.
Could you just--
Yes, yes.
And you know what, if the
egg falls, you get two stars.
And he'd be like got it.
At that point--
I love this idea.
Now it's not just a
regular egg and I realize
that an egg, it will roll off.
It's an egg that's sitting on a little...
What do you call it?
It's got a pedestal.
A pedestal.
And then it can teeter off
in any way.
Its natural state is to be balanced
and if there's a sudden stop--
But I didn't say anything.
Yeah.
Here's an even more pointed example.
This morning on the Uber,
I almost sat in the front seat
but then it drastically
increases the chances that I have
to talk to the driver
so I sat in the backseat
and I got car sick 'cause
the guy's herky jerkying
all over the place like bustin'
the egg that I don't have
'cause the brilliant idea
had not been hatched.
Yeah.
But that wasn't the thing.
The thing was he's getting
in the carpool lane.
I was like oh this is
good, we're passing a lot
of people on the 134, whatever that is.
And then it's like we
gotta get on the five.
But he's over here in the
134 and I look at his GPS
and you can get out of the carpool lane,
it's got the dotted lines
like this is the place
that he needs to get over to
take my exit onto the five.
Yeah, can't wait too late.
And he's dartin' and he's going so fast
and I look at his GPS and
first of all, he had a GPS
and most of 'em do but you'd
be surprised how many drivers
never look at the GPS 'cause
it's down on their lap
or something and he
had it mounted up there
so I could see it, I'm
like okay, I like this guy.
And it still said 134 so
it was not telling him
to get on the five yet.
In the next few yards
it actually did change
but by that point he was
trapped in the carpool lane
and could not legally exit.
Oh gosh.
But I'm seeing all
this unfold and we're
back a couple of notches.
It's still telling him to
stay in the carpool lane
or on the 134.
I know he needs to exit,
but I couldn't say anything.
Just like for the previous 10 minutes,
it was hot as Hades in the backseat
and I could not bring myself
to ask him to turn the AC up.
Really, I've seen you
do that with a driver.
I've seen you ask--
And I'm having this
internal dialogue--
For an adjustment before.
It's not worth it, it's not worth it.
Somehow me asking him to
change the AC is not nice.
It's like...
I'll blame you, you've guilted
me into not putting my--
Thanks.
Peculiarity onto people.
So--
Well.
And then so I couldn't
even tell him to exit
and then he's going
straight and he's trapped
in the carpool lane, I'm
like this is gonna add 15
to 20 minutes to my ride.
Yeah this could be
disastrous.
Because this is horrible.
Yeah this could be the end of the world.
And so I'm like I really
think you need to get,
you need to take this exit.
But there's no real way
out of the carpool lane.
He was like oh, and at
that point the GPS changed
to say he needed to exit
and he just broke the law
and just did it--
Good.
And I'm like I'm so glad he did that.
Even if he'd have broke
the egg at that point,
I would've--
Yeah.
Given him five stars but he's going over
and I'm like, yeah, the GPS
is always late at this point.
I'm totally lying.
Yeah that's--
I'm making this up.
Not true.
I'm totally making this up.
Yeah, making him feel good.
Yeah the GPS, the only
thing I've said to the guy
besides that was your
exit was then a yeah,
the GPS is always late at this point
and it's difficult 'cause you're trapped
in the carpool lane.
Yeah.
And he's like, what did he say?
He said something weird and I was like,
is he talking to me or himself?
It was like--
It was basically like,
yeah, I'm fine, man.
It was like that, I'm fine, man.
Yeah I've done this before.
I don't need your commentary.
And I was like I was trying to be nice.
Or encouragement.
I think, you know--
He was saying he didn't
need the emotional support
that you were offering.
Yeah, probably didn't.
It's just, I'm so,
it's just hard to tell
a driver what you want.
It's like is he my driver at this moment?
Hey you know what, you
should be in the far,
I have so many opinions, you know?
I do know.
And it's like but even I
am overridden with niceness
at that point, to a fault.
Well I have--
Missing exists and stuff.
I also Ubered in and had Ubered to the gym
and then Ubered from the gym to here
and so I had two different
drivers this morning
and driver number one,
I sat in the front seat
'cause he had a very
small car and I was like,
sometimes in the backseat with me,
my head will hit the ceiling.
Yeah you got--
Most cars actually.
Got your chin on your knees.
And you know, there was some
small talk about the weather
and I was like is this gonna
turn into a conversation?
Mm.
Of course I'm hoping not.
He brought up the weather
'cause you're in the front seat.
Yeah I know, I'm inviting this.
But I was told that the app will now,
you can indicate on the app
if you're a conversationalist
or not and I know I said that--
I haven't looked into that.
You said you're not.
What?
A conversationalist.
I was told that that option exists
but I have not seen it either.
I don't know any of the options.
So I ended up just kinda
getting on my phone
and then I start thinking, again,
I feel like if you look at a pie chart
of my brain activity at this point,
at least 10%, sometimes
revving up to 30 to 40%
of my brain activity is focused
on what this guy thinks of me.
And it isn't even in the
context of what his rating
is gonna be of me.
It's literally like does
guy gonna think I'm a jerk
because I'm on my phone the whole time
or is he gonna think that
I'm addicted to my phone?
Like why do I care?
Who cares?
Even saying nice things
is not really about being
nice and maybe this is the key
to unlocking some new
practice is the realization
that our niceties are much more about us
and about shaping perception than it is
about actually being nice to somebody,
being kind to someone.
I think a lot of it is just rooted in ego.
Yeah.
I do.
I think there is, this
very human things to do,
but I think that one of the reasons that
sometimes you may
interpret an older person
as being blunt or not nice,
sometimes they are just jerks,
but I think in a lot of
cases it's that they have
actually lost some of their
ego as they've gotten older
which if you're healthy
I think is the direction
that you should be heading in,
you're getting less
and less about yourself
and more and more about
others as you get older,
and so I do think that,
and I like to use the word candidness
because I do think that
sometimes that's what it is,
it's just like this person
told me what they thought.
And again, it's not being super,
I do think that sometimes
being super particular
about things and then expecting
everybody to fall in line,
that can become an annoying thing, right?
But I don't think that's
what asking somebody
to adjust the temperature if
you're hot in an Uber is about.
I think it's like well I kinda
don't wanna be burning up
back here and I know
that this person probably
actually does care about
what temperature it is.
Some drivers ask you is it
okay, is it okay back there?
So it's reasonable and not
jerky to say something about it.
But I think that a big part of it is just
reputation management with people
that you'll never see
again which is weird.
Yeah.
But it's just this
wanting so badly to be liked
and to not ruffle feathers
that you end up doing
a disservice to people.
And I do think that we--
And yourself
'cause you're blazin' up in the backseat.
I think that's a term for smoking weed
and that's not what I mean.
Right, yeah yeah.
But I think there's also a
button for that on the app.
My name is D-Nice.
I'm gonna blaze up, just be ready.
I'm a conversationalist blazer.
I've never thought about that
but I have thought about,
can I just bring Jade in an Uber?
This is just a tangent
but I was wondering that this morning.
And again for niceness I was like--
I would think so.
I don't want a negative rating
'cause this whole rating
thing is part of it too.
It's a quantified version
of what we're talking about.
It's like I'm gonna treat
you in a way not that I want
to be treated or just
because you're another human
that I wanna be nice to,
I wanna treat you in a way
so that you will give me
a good rating.
That's messed up, man.
I literally think about my rating on Uber.
I have no clue what it is
and I don't think it has
any bearing on anything.
I don't know when it comes into play
and I don't know when people
can come to a conclusion
about it, I don't necessarily--
But if Jade was just sittin' in my lap,
she'd be here right now.
I don't think it would be a problem.
I guess there are some Uber, maybe all--
Plenty of people who'd have a problem
with a dog in their car.
Maybe all ride share operators
have to be okay with dogs.
Maybe they indicate that
somewhere on the app.
Maybe, I don't know, it's a good question.
You don't know the ins and outs--
Especially with, Jade is not a giant dog.
If you have a Great Dane
or something like that
that could be a problem.
I could keep her hidden,
wouldn't even know she was there.
Yeah so, what about niceness
when it comes to content
because the stuff that we create,
there are entire channels built on,
well, of course there's entire
channels built on drama.
I'm not really, I'm not
talking about drama as much as,
I don't know, I guess this
is a bordering territory
to it that I'll just
call the hot takes, man.
You've got an opinion on something.
So much and it's not just digital content
but radio for years, television,
all types of talk content
is, we can talk about it as
it relates to Ear Biscuits,
is successful because
it's just, it's hot takes.
It's opinions, I mean and a
lot of times there's a lot of,
it's super charged with
some vitriol, some anger,
some bitterness, some
complaints, the opposite of being nice.
Being brutally honest or
just having a punchy opinion.
And that's not...
Maybe we started to do a little
bit of that but not really.
I think that when we, on
Ear Biscuits, we kinda...
We resist the urge to give
our unfettered opinions
on things because,
do you think there's a
niceness component there?
What's going on there?
Are we too nice when it
comes to our content?
Well I think that's part of it.
I think it's really
complex because I do think
that there is just something
about our personalities
naturally whether it's niceness
or however you would wanna describe it
that we don't tend to be,
we're both opinionated
for sure but when it comes
to the types of opinions and hot takes
that would be the kinda thing that would,
people would care about on the internet,
that's not really a natural
part of our dialogue.
We don't spend a lot of
time thinking and talking
about those things but I also think that
because we were so focused
on just making people laugh
and for a number of reasons
and we'll probably do a podcast
on this at some point, why
we approached our content
the way we did in the early days
and why it started so family friendly,
more family friendly than it is now.
Still generally family
friendly but it was like
squeaky clean G-rated
from the very beginning.
Yeah.
I think you attract
a certain audience it's like,
oh these guys are gonna something
that never offends people
and it's just all about being lighthearted
and then when you build
a fan base around that,
you've kinda cornered
yourself a little bit,
whereas, one of the things that Harley
from the Epic Mealtime said,
probably at this table,
was that you kinda get what
you give to your audience.
You get back what you give
and he gives his tone,
especially at the time was
very harsh towards his audience
and you kind of attract people
who like that kinda thing
and then they kinda give it back.
So I think that we've actually developed
a pretty nice community
because the content isn't
vitriolic in any way.
And we're proud of that.
Right.
That is something to be proud of.
That's a good thing.
But even me saying that
right now is like oh I
don't want it to seem like
I'm being critical of our
core audience or an aspect
of our, a contingent of
our audience's taste.
Well here's a perfect example of--
'Cause I'm not being critical of you.
Where I think that the
audience that we cultivated
and how nice they were and
are, for the most part,
created a content problem for us
and that is with our
local commercials, right,
we've talked about this a number of times.
Yeah that's a good case study.
We've never really been
into prank content per se.
We did that one prank video.
We've done a number of pranks like all
of our man on the street videos--
Yeah they were--
Were--
They're kinda prank-inspired
and they're kinda--
Made people feel awkward
at least.
They're based on making
normal people feel a
little bit out of sorts
and getting some laughs at their expense.
Not in a super mean-spirited
way but for some people,
anything in that realm is mean-spirited.
And the nature of the local
commercials that we made back
in the day and then on Commercial Kings,
which is still back in the
day, this is a long time ago,
of course we used real
businesses and real people
from those businesses and the
thing that we found so funny
is when we put normal people
into these situations,
these ridiculous structures
that we created for them
and they just did their thing.
You're kinda laughing at slash with them,
and everybody ends up being
happy and it's good for business
and people love the result
but one of the reasons that--
It's not clear-cut though.
A lot of people are
uncomfortable with it is because
a really, really strict
interpretation of it is that
you're laughing at these people,
you're having fun and
humor at their expense.
And some people are not
comfortable with that at all.
So now, we are both very
comfortable with that.
It's a little bit of a generational thing.
I do think that the younger generation is
much less comfortable with
it although I will say
that even though I didn't encourage this,
my kids are much like I was at their age.
Some people can't watch the
show that we talked about,
Impractical Jokers, some
people can't watch that
'cause they're like I just don't like
to see anybody being made
to feel uncomfortable.
They love it.
They think it's great.
But we ended up stopping
doing those commercials
because we just ended up
getting, one of the reasons
was we just ended up
getting so much push-back
'cause people would be like,
this doesn't seem like,
this isn't the stuff
that I like you guys for.
This just seems a little bit mean.
Mean-spirited.
And so we just were like
okay well, it's not like
we have to keep doing this.
We did a bunch of it, we can
move onto something else.
So I do think that that is
an example of our niceness
in general and especially
in things like GMM,
cultivating an audience that
then couldn't really take
the non-nice content.
Yeah and I was talking
to Arin from Game Grumps
and he was talking about
his, their talk show,
which is inspired format-wise
by Good Mythical Morning.
The 10 Minute Power Hour.
Which we're big fans of.
And he was talking about how, he said,
he was talking about the GMM influence
on how they created that but
he was like, but we've got,
the tone is a little different
'cause we got a bit more
of that eff you energy.
You guys don't really have eff you energy
and I was saying something
about their Reddit contingent
and he was like,
the people that respond to
that are the people who then,
they'll like eff you in the comments
but then when we looked at how
much merch we were selling,
they have a whole Reddit thread that them
or none of their crew
has anything to do with
because it's just all the
fans who just hate on them.
But he said that a remarkable percentage,
of course I don't remember the number
'cause I don't have mental capacity
to remember other people's numbers.
Right, you're thinking
about your vacation.
He said that it was a big
contingent of merch sales
are from those people who are
constantly eff you, eff you.
Because they're very
invested and they're fans.
It's just--
It's a different way
of expressing--
You get what you give
and I'm a little envious of that energy
because I don't know,
from a comedic standpoint,
it seems, I don't know what the word is,
it just seems more emphatic.
Comedically emphatic, when
you're doing something
that can be, is edgy,
quite literally edgy so it
pushes you either one way
or the other, right?
It's easy to subconsciously feel like
that's a more legitimate form of comedy
because it's sending you
in one of two directions,
either love or hate versus just like...
I think our tone, it's very welcoming.
Oh I can tolerate it, as
where someone may be left.
And I think that we end
up compensating for it
a little bit because again,
if we were just completely ourselves,
throw caution to the wind,
we would be more offensive than we are.
If there was no guard up at all as to
what is a more broadly appealing,
welcoming sort of tone,
it would be a more caustic tone.
It just would be.
Of course we have more
opinions than we share.
Yeah and also--
And I know that people
are gonna say they want more of that.
Well and you might think that--
Now that we're talking about it.
You might just say well
I can see that coming
from Rhett but from
Link, no, the reality is,
it would come from both of,
I don't wanna speak for you.
Yeah, no--
It's not just a thing
that comes from the bitter tall one.
But interestingly, you're
also kinda talking about
stand-up comedy as an example,
the purest form of comedy, right?
Which we've never really, we do it kind of
but we haven't done traditional stand-up,
definitely not alone.
I thought farts were
the purest form of comedy.
Go ahead.
Are you saying that because my seat
just made a farting noise?
No I was just making a joke.
The whole give and take that
you have with an audience
and the fact that if
you're going to speak up
to a comedian, he or she is
going to rip you a new one
and that's part of the act.
Heckling and then responding
to hecklers is part
of being a great stand-up and--
A certain type of stand-up though.
I don't think that
applies to all stand-up.
Well no no, even the nicest comedian.
Like a Brian Regan.
Even the nicest comedian.
A Gaffigan.
Is not going, Gaffigan,
okay, is not, I guarantee
you that when he does
his live stand-up and somebody heckles him
that he gets the best of them.
Oh yeah.
Because you can't exist.
How mean-spirited is it?
We kinda do that on tour.
We don't do anything that's
ridiculously vindictive
or whatever but if you're
gonna have the courage
to speak up at our tour, we're
gonna end up doing something
that's gonna make people laugh at you.
But it's all in good fun.
I definitely don't wanna
get into a place where
we're not willing to just,
light ribbing is no longer allowed.
But how, I think the question is is like,
how does it work its way into the content?
What are we afraid of?
And how do you navigate it?
Because just another quick data point is
when we were guests on the H3 Podcast.
Big fans of Ethan and Hila
and their growing family
of sons and dogs, well
they've got one of each.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's hot take central over there.
And it's extremely entertaining.
It's hot takes for the
sake of entertainment.
That's why I enjoyed it.
It's almost like taking a
position just for the laughs
a lot of time, not all the time.
And so being on there was like...
I think when it comes to the
type of things they talk about,
you're more informed and more opinionated
about those specific
things so that felt like
more of an outlet for you to be there
than it did for me.
I think there were other
things that would get me going.
Probably germs.
Or herky jerky Uber drivers.
But the type of stuff they
talk about was something that,
I mean we don't go into
that stuff on our podcast.
Smosh does some of that on their podcast.
Because it is a great
way to develop a fan base
if that's something, if
that's a way you're interested
in talking about things.
But it's...
I don't, you tell me what you think.
I don't think that's a place where,
we've made a decision
that that's not what,
that's not the type of place that we go.
And I'm not talking about
YouTube drama as much as
current event hot take
type stuff where it's,
you cannot be nice.
You cannot come across
as nice, that's not part
of the equation in those conversations.
Well, I feel like trying
to incorporate drama or commentary
about controversial things
into what we're currently doing
would be a little bit of a betrayal.
Because I feel like there's
so much of that, right?
All out there.
We're not just throwing what
we create into a vacuum.
It is experienced in the
greater context of internet
and entertainment in general.
And we are so polarized right now, right?
So as opinionated as I am
and as bitter as I can be
about some things,
I do think there's something to be said
for the fact that our show
and our content in general
is something people can
come together over, around.
People of differing backgrounds,
people of differing political opinions
should be able to come
to our show and be like
this is something that we can agree on.
And I do think there's power in that.
Some people call it a cop-out,
some people say you're doing
that just so you can make
more money and have a
broadly appealing product.
I actually personally and I think I speak
for both of us but I know
that that's something
that I care about is I
don't like the disunity
in our world and in our country.
It's needed now more than ever.
And I think that--
Something that brings
us together.
And I do think
that we're kind of especially equipped
to kinda bring people together.
We understand multiple perspectives,
having embodied multiple
perspectives over the course
of our lives and I think that that puts us
in a position to be like hey,
all these people aren't bad
and all these people aren't bad.
It's like hey, let's have a dialogue.
There are some things
that we can agree on.
Now we don't end up talking directly
about those things very often.
So I do think it would be
a little bit of disservice
to be like all of a sudden
we're gonna be talking
about all this stuff and
we're gonna be throwing
our opinions out there and
blasting people who disagree.
That's just not the spirit of what we do.
But I do think the thing
that, one of the reasons
that what Ethan and Hila do is appealing
or what Game Grumps does
is appealing is because
it's more fun to just let your guard down.
It's more fun to just
be honest and be like
I don't really care about the
impact or the consequences
because I'm just being myself.
To have a little filter and a
guard on everything you say,
it's a little bit tiresome so I do think
that as you get older
and I think this is one
of the reason that there is
more innuendo as an example
in all of our content now
than there was when we started
is because you know what,
when we talk privately,
it's a lot of innuendo.
We both find sexual
innuendo to be very funny
and we use a lot of it in
our normal private lives.
So--
We also did when we were
in seventh grade.
We've always done it.
Do you remember--
From the very beginning.
But we haven't done it in our content.
Right.
Until it's 1500, 1600 episodes,
you just come a little bit more yourself
and I think that there's
something freeing about that.
And that's a place, I think
the sexual innuendo's a place
where we've, we've talked about it some
and we continue to talk
about the ways that we,
the lines, the ways that we
will incorporate innuendo
and the ways we won't so we
know what our best practices are
to use the corporate term.
But in an effort to
conclude this conversation,
I think that it's...
I need to have a prolonged thought.
We've got time.
Yeah in an effort to come to a conclusion,
I think that we can, I
feel good with the summary
that you've given of hey,
we're trying to create things
in conversations where it
can be an outlet for anybody.
That simple.
Well I would say that that's a principle
that applies to our content.
We don't wanna be a dividing force.
We don't wanna be a
polarizing force in the world
because there's enough of that already.
That doesn't mean that
there are some things
that we consider to be
non-political but just human issues
that need to be addressed
that we will take a stand on
and talk about and that's at
our discretion as we see fit
but I think that as time goes by,
we will continue to be
more and more ourselves.
Yeah I think it's, yeah,
the balancing point
just to piggyback on that is,
yeah, we're not gonna be fake.
We're not gonna be nice and
lie, lie through our teeth
just to be nice.
Yeah.
I wanna be nice when I
actually mean what I'm saying.
I don't wanna say anything
here that I do not mean.
Exactly.
So I think
that's why we choose our
topics of conversation.
And I think that I've
seen, you see the chatter
and the speculation sometimes
when people are trying
to figure out what things
lead to the evolution
of the show over time or the way we talk.
And I think one of the accusations
that can be levied sometimes is that oh,
you guys are continuing
to push the boundaries
because you want your
content to be more accepted
or you're doing this to get more attention
or to get people to care about you
and I think that, well,
the reality is is that
we've kinda always talked this way
but the longer we do it, the
more the layers get pulled back
and you see who we are.
And personally that's something that,
I've been focusing on
this personally a lot
just through therapy honestly,
it's just getting out of my
head, getting into my heart,
living more from a place of feeling
because I've done enough thinking.
I've done a lot of thinking.
And I think part of that is
continuing to kinda let go
of what people think about you,
continuing to have your
ego hopefully continue
to be drained as you get older.
And I think just a natural result of that
is that you're just
gonna be more of yourself
and so the things that
we do aren't a result
of trying to be provocative,
of trying to get more views,
we're always going to be
trying to get more views,
we're trying to be successful
but it's really us being more
of ourselves and I think that ultimately
to tie it back to the original question,
it's that we're not as
nice as you think we are
if you thought we were really nice.
And that's a broad word but I think that
if some of these things--
But there is a core niceness
that we're striving to be nice
as long as it's true to ourselves.
Yeah.
#EarBiscuits, let us know what you think.
Join in on the conversation.
Recs in Effect.
I'll give a music rec.
Been listening to The Bahamas.
I don't think I've rec'ed Bahamas.
I think we've talked about it personally
'cause I'm like, we used to
really be into Jack Johnson,
that laid-back, you talk about
Roy and his Hawaiian vibe
with his elevator, the elevator goes slow
when you're listening to some
Jack Johnson back in the day.
Bahamas is kinda like
my updated Jack Johnson.
And the specific song that
I'm gonna recommend is,
gotta turn, why I gotta turn my,
gotta take it out of airport mode.
I know it's airplane mode.
Off the album, Bahamas is Afie.
I think that's the guy's first name.
A-F-I-E.
"All The Time"'s a good song.
But "Stronger Than That", you
start listening to that song
and it sounds like
"Islands in the Stream".
Kenny Rogers, Dolly Parton duo, duet.
And then, I mean you think
he's just gonna start singing
like Kenny Rogers but then he doesn't.
Are they from the Bahamas?
He sings like Bahamas, it's one guy.
Is he from the Bahamas?
No, I think he just channels that vibe.
Okay.
I can't say.
But if you like that vibe, check it out.
Especially that song.
Yes thanks for sticking with us,
for listening to this conversation
that we didn't know where it was gonna go
but it went where it went
and it'll continue to go
where it's gonna go but it's
not gonna go anywhere next week
or for the next three weeks
because we're taking a little break.
We'll be back on August eight,
what is it?
19th.
August 19th.
August 19th, we'll be back
from our epic vacations.
We'll be talking to you about those.
Until then, #EarBiscuits.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.